un nouveau chapitre pour la librairie
lettres voisine de voisins-le-bretonneux
fermé depuis janvier 2020 faute de
repreneur une solution a été trouvée
pour une réouverture dans de nouveaux
locaux loués par la mairie ça fait un
bout de temps que l'être voisines
avaient fermé et c'est toujours très
triste une librairie qui ferment et donc
je suis là aujourd'hui juste pas pour
acheter des livres aujourd'hui mais en
tous les cas pour vérifier qu'elle est
bien ouvert on attendait depuis
plusieurs mois on ne savait pas en fait
ce que ce que c'était devenu on a été
très attristée par par sa fermeture et
donc au vrai c'est une super nouvelle
mille livres neufs et plus de 2000
livres d'occasion sont déjà à
disposition une réouverture poussé par
christine sauvage libraire emblématique
de la ville avec trente années
d'ancienneté qui a soutenu la relance du
projet le fait de recréer quelque chose
toutes façons c'est une bonne chose
c'est surtout de voir que un projet qui
était peut-être par moments on voyait ne
pas se réaliser de voir se réaliser
c'est quand même mon grand bénéfice et
du coup la retraite se passe très bien
une solution qui reste précaire
christine sauvage et son binôme françois
vernon également sorti de la retraite
assure tas de l'ouverture en attendant
de trouver un libraire pour reprendre le
poste il a fallu reprendre un petit peu
les choses au mois de janvier
imaginez une autre construction à une
autre organisation
dans quelque temps il faudra à nouveau
trouvé vraiment
un professionnel qui reprennent
l'ensemble est qui qui se relance à
partir de ce que nous avons rouvert
aujourd'hui la mairie louant les locaux
pour un peu plus de deux ans il s'agira
également et avant l'expiration du bail
de trouver un futur espace pour les
lettres voisine